free societies tend to do a very good
job in responding
to human needs libertarian intellectual
charles murray
is perhaps america's most influential
social policy thinker
born in 1943 in the small town of newton
iowa
murray spent six years in the peace
corps stationed in thailand and went on
to earn a doctorate in political science
from mit in 1974.
murray started out as a liberal democrat
but he underwent a political
transformation while researching his
landmark
1984 book losing ground the book
marshaled overwhelming evidence that
american welfare programs were harming
the very people they were supposed to be
lifting
out of poverty when you try to do things
for other people that they are not
prepared to do for themselves
it's very difficult to achieve anything
losing ground was fiercely denounced by
the political left but soon won
wide acceptance that the war on poverty
was at least partially a failure the
simple fact is
there wouldn't have been welfare reform
without losing ground
far more controversial was the bell
curve murray's 1994 collaboration with
harvard psychologist richard hernstein
we were convinced that iq is an
important phenomenon and trying to
understand what's going on in society
that book maintained that differences in
genes contribute to differences in iq
those differences in turn play a
significant role in the life outcomes of
individuals
most controversially the book argued
that various ethnic groups have distinct
albeit marginal differences
in inherited intelligence the commentary
on this book
shows the bankruptcy of the american
media
in dealing with difficult topics murray
is the author of more than 20 books
including what it means to be a
libertarian a personal interpretation
in his new book coming apart the state
of white america 1960-2010
murray argues that americans are
becoming divided into two distinct
classes and that this growing divide
could end american life as we've known
it
murray's analysis focuses on white
americans as a way of highlighting that
the negative social trends he identifies
do
not break along racial or ethnic lines
murray is currently the w.h brady
scholar at the american enterprise
institute
i sat down with him in march for a
wide-ranging discussion of how his prior
work has led to coming apart well first
of all thank you very much for coming in
to talk to us every reason
it's good to see you ron it's been a
while yeah as you know you're here
talking with reason magazine
reason tv you call yourself a
libertarian what does that mean
for you what do you mean by that so i'm
a lower case libertarian
essentially i think what madison thought
and what jefferson thought in terms of
the original
structure of government and its proper
limits
uh so i'm i'm libertarian
on all but the purest to pure things for
example i'm in favor of drug
legalization uh i'm not real upset about
laws against child pornography and
things like that to just give an example
of
where i park company with real purists
in your new book coming apart the state
of white america
1960 to 2010 is is
a valedictory about a victory of your
long discourse on the
intersection between happiness and
public policy public policy
public policy's purpose is to better
enable people to pursue happiness
how does it do it and with that in mind
let's start with your first big book
losing ground it seems to me in that
book you made the following sort of
argument that poverty is like anything
else the more you pay for it the more
you can have of it yeah the the
statement i made in the forward or the
introduction of that book was that in
the 1960s we changed the rules of the
game
for for low-income people and especially
for low-income
young people and that we changed the
rules in the game in the ways that made
short-term incentives such that they did
really stupid things
in in the long term so basically it was
about incentives people were being
killed
it was about incentives and uh and and
i've
i tried to make the point that a lot of
times you don't have to appeal
to exotic cultural explanations for why
people do things
just assume that whatever they're doing
makes sense to them
at least at the moment they're doing it
in a recent interview about losing
ground you said
you argued that you still believed that
the reforms of the 60s jump-started
a lot of the trends that you currently
deplore and that toothpaste cannot be
put back in the tube just by reversing a
few welfare state policies
yet in losing ground you apparently
thought you could put some of the
toothpaste back
in the tube i was writing in 1980
and in 1980 you still had in the white
population for example
you were still looking i was writing in
the early 1980s you still had
out of wedlock births in the low teens i
believe
in terms of percentage of births you
still had a culture
in which of getting married was a strong
cultural norm
we're looking at 2012 now and in 2012 if
you take
all births in the united states of all
races and so forth you're looking at
about
40 percent of them are out of wedlock
you have seen a change in a cultural
norm
which has enormous power in the early
1980s
there was still some stigma certainly in
the white community
associated with having a baby without a
husband that's gone
effectively it's gone a variety of other
changes have occurred in sexual behavior
in expectations of women in the
workforce
a whole bunch of things have happened
which means that before you can make
policy changes that are going to have
much effect
you've got to have some cultural changes
but in losing ground you had hoped at
least
may i quote here you called for
scrapping the entire
federal welfare income support structure
medicaid food stamps unemployment
workers compensation subsidized housing
the whole thing the whole thing
and such a step would leave working-age
person with no recourse whatsoever
except the job market family members
friends and public and private
locally funded services can we get rid
of a lot of welfare programs
okay no you know i'm in an odd situation
when it comes to the welfare reform act
of 1996 because
a lot of people say well losing ground
was the intellectual impetus that led to
that
which of course i i want to believe and
i want to take credit for it
but i also say the welfare reform act of
1996 borne no relationship
to what i was proposing it was a single
program the afdc
cash program to which there were changes
and changes that led to a lot of people
getting off the welfare roles
uh something we could talk about at
length as to why that happened
but there remained a big support
structure in place didn't touch
the food stamps program didn't touch
medicaid didn't touch
public housing didn't touch a whole
bunch of other things here's the irony
the left got so excited about the
welfare reform act saying it was going
to lead to
uh calcutta on the hudson or which i
think was pat moynihan's phrase or
something like that
they propagandized welfare recipients
saying you know the sky is falling the
sky is falling if this thing passed
and when it did pass they believed him
you had lots of people who left the
roles just after it passed and before
anything else had happened
also you had lots of people who were
working off the books
so they were getting their afdc and they
were holding jobs and all at once
they couldn't continue working off the
books as easily because
the they were supposed to be putting in
uh efforts to get jobs
and it got kind of awkward when you
actually were already holding on to a
job
so what you had was i should have been a
lesson for us
for lots of other reforms as well just
make it more of a hassle
you know if getting if getting
assistance were as difficult as getting
a driver's license is in some
department's motor vehicles for example
like the dc department the last time i
was there
it's amazing how much we could cut back
on recipients of welfare benefits
so incentives did matter in that sense
sure oh and i still believe incentives
matter
uh what i'm saying in the current book
is you
we don't have anything in the political
landscape
that would permit changes that affect
incentives enough
to produce much of an effect socialist
intellectual michael harrington
critiqued
your work in losing ground as rather
crudely
as he said the equivalent of a vulgar
marxist
a social theorist who believes in a
one-to-one relationship between economic
and the political or the psychological
weren't you actually in some sense
advocating a kind of economic
determinism in that book
um there gee there's a chapter in that
book entitled the destruction of status
rewards
and the destruction of status rewards
said you know what a lot of these
changes and behavior come from
a lot of them come in the from the fact
that it used to be
that if you were a low-income guy who
was holding down a job and supporting a
wife and children
you got status in your community
as one of the good guys and if you
didn't do those things you got
stigmatized as one of the bad ones
well those are incentives all right
they're not economic incentives
they're cultural incentives uh to say
that i am an economic determinist
is to have a very selective reading of
losing ground
on the other hand the the core of what
caused
the falling apart if you will as i
understood from the book was the rise of
the welfare state which was all about
economic incentives for the most part
but they affected the state as rewards
you know
when you have a change and this is
especially true of the welfare chain
it has cascading secondary effects
and the reason i now say
you know policy changes aren't going to
make that much difference is it set in
motion
all of these other cultural outcomes
including the destruction of status
rewards uh including
i would say the infantilization of males
uh but that's incred in concert
with uh the feminist revolution and some
other things as well feminist revolution
to a certain extent has been a great
good for women
absolutely exactly so that part of it
isn't inevitable i
i think that that the status between
males and females would have changed
well actually it is suppose you have
no changes in the welfare rules at all
i'm sorry welfare incentives
suppose none of the mistakes of the
1960s were made but
you did have the same entry of women
into the labor force okay so you have
the feminist revolution
without any of the policy mistakes what
you would have then in low-income
communities are more and more women
who are making money on their own
and in a lot of cases making enough
money that
it's significant and they could support
the child on their own so in that sense
you've already got
a weakening of the incentive to marry
because economically it's not as crucial
as it was before
but this but another thing happens
suppose at that point the woman says
well i still want to get married because
my father needs a child
my father a child needs a father okay so
they get married
the guy's position is different now he's
still holding down a job let's say
but she's making just as much money
because she's continuing her job
so yeah he's helping to put food in the
table
that's different from being the man
he's now a partner in this marriage and
i think partnership in marriage is a
good idea
so i'm i'm saying as a father of three
daughters i'm glad the feminist
revolution occurred
it inevitably took for low-income men
a major prop away from their self-esteem
and their dignity
it could not have been otherwise and
that all by itself was going to make a
big difference
then you add on that to that the sexual
revolution
right so
the guy the sexual revolution had not
occurred
you had women going into the labor force
but sexual norms were still the same
and then the guy would still have a good
incentive to marry because
if the only way you're going to get
regular sexual access to women is to be
married you're going to get married
in so far as that's no longer necessary
a big incentive for guys when they're
young
to get married diminishes that's just
the truth about males
what do you suppose the net effect of
that is going to be what's the point of
getting married so what do you do about
that then
you can't take either of those back it
has nothing to do with the incentives of
the welfare estate at all it's a
exactly so so now you go back and say
well do we have any objective reality on
our side
i would submit a major source of
satisfaction in life
is a good marriage in order to have a
good marriage you got to get married
so when i'm talking about cultural
shifts i'm not saying
we've got to make up stuff to try to
propagandize people into doing what we
want
what we need to do is to start talking
more openly
about the objective rightness of these
behaviors on the other hand the notion
of companion in marriage is what i'm
taking that you're thinking about
to some extent is a fairly new notion in
human history
uh if you go back to the 19th century
and so forth one description of marriage
is a man and a woman standing back to
back
fighting against the forces trying to
destroy their family those forces went
away to a large
part of modern society and they turned
on each other instead
and you saw divorce rates increased
because people started expecting more
for marriage
than they used than they were getting is
that not a plausible part of what
also happened during the 1950s first
let's go back to the 19th century and
before
when indeed love was not the basis for
making marriages
tocqueville talks about the marriage in
19th century america in some very
interesting ways
specifically he says in america they
don't arrange marriages
okay so they raise the daughters to
choose husbands wisely
and that's the way that americans can
get away
with marriage which has such very strict
obligations
because they are making marriages with
mature decisions
and he has this wonderful passage at the
end of the book where he says
to what do i attribute all of these
wonderful qualities of the united states
and he says i attribute it to primarily
to the superiority of american women
okay so you have a an institution in the
united states
uh in which women still may not have
been choosing for love
they were choosing on the basis of
people being good providers
good fathers to their children so forth
love in marriage
does not consist of this burning desire
to jump into bed with each other that
you feel at 20 years old it consists of
a shared life and a growing
companionship
and a depth of human connection that's
very difficult to describe to an
outsider
i think that developed i won't say as
frequently
because i don't know but i think that
was a very common feature
of 19th century marriages the next big
book the one that
caused you a lot of heartburn was the
bell curve the way i interpret that move
from
losing ground you'll correct me if i'm
wrong to this is that you went from
an incentive explanation for a lot of
the things that have gone wrong with
american society and growing inequality
to one
based on more cognitive constraints that
basically
the society was sorting on the basis of
ability would that be a fair
sort of that's that's that's a good
description and it was
the same sort of social problems were
being identified with
those causes well if you go to the last
chapter of
the bell curve uh you see us address
that question directly
we said that what we are doing now is we
are creating a world
which is congenial to people with high
iqs
people with high iqs love complexity
they think complexity is fun
that's why you have kohlberg at harvard
coming up with his stages of moral
reasoning
which has seven stages uh you know at
the primitive level people just
think certain things are right and wrong
but at a sophisticated level you
understand that sometimes it's okay to
steal
in service of a higher good okay that is
theoretically true
i even believe it that that it can be
okay to steal in service of a higher
good but
a kind of moral world governed by that
kind of complexity
is real hard to deal with if you aren't
very smart
it's much simpler if you are
you know not an intellectual to have a
criminal justice system which is based
on very clear
simple straightforward statements of if
you do this
which is really bad uh objectively
you will get a penalty and what
that means is you want a state in which
the things that are against the law
are things that everybody agrees or bad
robbery
murder rape so forth uh
have you changed any of those laws
though as i understand it those all
those are all still bad
and we have a thousand other things that
are also against the law
in which it's not really that so that
obvious that it's so bad
because very few low iq people i suspect
are following a foul of those new laws
of those complex new
tax laws those complex new
laws laws against smoking a joint and
things like that
you don't think they're falling afoul of
that that's true uh okay uh
in terms of all kinds of laws though
including the laws against
robbery rape murder and so forth i
evaluated a program
in south side chicago in the 1970s for
chronic juvenile delinquents
and i would talk to kids who were
outraged that they'd finally been sent
to the can
because they would say to me i'd done
things lots worse than that and been
caught for them they didn't do anything
to me why they do anything now
they were looking at a system which
behaved utterly irrationally from their
point of view
they didn't see it as one which was
being forgiving hoping that they would
do better and finally saying
i guess now we'll have to sanction you
they saw a system that made no sense
whatsoever
the same thing has happened with all
kinds of aspects of life
the phrase we used in the bell curve
actually was stolen from ed crane
and he said what you're saying is that
everybody has a moral compass
but some of them are more susceptible to
magnetic storms than others
i think that's a brilliant avocation of
what i'm saying and what you want to
construct
is a society in which it is easy for
people of a broad range of ability
to be morally autonomous and guess what
that's a libertarian society now of
course a lot of critics at the time
pressed you very hard on the question of
racial and ethnic differences in iq
uh nearly 20 years later you still see
those differences
as significant would you tell me
anything in
the data that has changed in those 20
years i mean
i've done more research into it uh since
then and it
looks to me like this uh the
the diff black white difference in iq
measurements of which go back to the
early 20th century
narrowed substantially for for uh black
and
blacks and whites born in the 30s 40s
50s and 60s
in the 1930s it was real big it was
not one standard deviation to use the
technical term it was closer to two
and it narrowed to about one uh
standard deviation maybe a little less
even among kids born through the 1960s
among kids born since the early 1970s
there has been no change in the black
white difference in any data set that
that i have yet seen
and that does not look good to me it is
consistent with what we said in the bell
curve
there remains a difference in means
that does not imply that all blacks are
less smart than all whites the
significance of group differences
is trivial as long as you treat people
as individuals which of course is the
key
james heckman who reviewed your book for
the reason for reason magazine many
years ago
said that you hadn't really looked at
all the data you might have that one of
the things that you could do
is an intervention that might be
successful and he said he had good data
for this and
in fact very recently had further update
on this
is you could have early childhood
programs five and earlier
where perhaps it might have to have huge
effects on cognitive development later
but had
huge effects on qualities like
industriousness
sharing abilities that you could
inculcate other qualities through
education and children that
ended up with huge benefits later down
the line yeah and he's using programs
like perry preschool
with a sample size of 50 in the control
group and 40 in the experimental or
something like that
look there heckman's a serious scholar
and and i don't dispute his
conclusion that these programs have an
effect
greater than zero i would not
even go to the mat and say the effects
are trivial
i think he is seeing a glass half full
that i see half empty
but if you want to spend money on things
early childhood
education is going to buy you more than
trying to jack up
k-12 education that's for sure and
children who are born
into severely disadvantaged
circumstances
for my money you don't have to prove
long-term outcomes
to say that putting a child from a
punishing environment into a
nurturing warm environment is a good
thing to do i hope they have more impact
i think he's more optimistic than the
data strictly warned
so one of the other things that that
seemed to be the conclusion of the bell
curve is that you were afraid that in
some sense rather the cognitive elite
that you identified was going to merge
with the fluent already effluent and
create a new upper class
and i believe that you're arguing that
that's actually happened yeah
yeah people ask me about
whether i think the bell curve is still
valid
i say look around they'd degree to which
we now have
a coincidence of the very affluent
with the very smart is palpably obvious
to everyone but you can also talk about
it more systematically as i try to do in
the new book
what would you say the thesis of the new
book is oh that's very easy
we have developed classes that are
different in kind from anything
we have known before take the case of
marriage cultural norm
for rich and poor alike back in 1960
about every almost everybody was married
when they were full-grown adults in
their 30s and 40s
94 in the upper middle class 84 percent
in the working class you go to 2010
marriage is still alive and well
in the upper middle class about 84
percent of adults are married
in the whites upper middle class it's
down to 48
in the white working class i mean that's
a stunning number
uh that's a divergence unlike anything
we've ever had before
in that sense second example
we had neighborhoods in 1960 which were
the cliche neighborhoods for where rich
people lived north shore chicago
beverly hills scarsdale and the rest of
westchester county
upper east upper west side upper east
side excuse me
northwest washington you know what the
mean income
in 14 of those classic rich
neighborhoods in 1960 was
it was expressed in current dollars
today's dollars
eighty four thousand eighty three
thousand dollars something like that
in other words half of the people made
less than eighty three eighty four
thousand dollars
in today's purchasing power which means
even in these richest neighborhoods you
had lots of people who didn't have that
much money
more importantly you only had about 26
percent of them with college degrees
so even the ones who were rich
oftentimes were high school graduates
so you know they were fully socialized
in mainstream america
go back and go to 2010 same 14
neighborhoods
163 thousand dollars median income
that's two
i'm sorry that's the 2000 census it's
going to be a lot higher now
when we get to the 2010 census 67
percent
with college degrees a lot of those
disproportionately high numbers from the
elite colleges
it's very far from mainstream america
and the isolation
is not so bad for people who have grown
up in working class families or middle
class families it's really problematic
when you have people rising to positions
of power who have never known anything
about that world
why is it problematic because they have
so much influence on the culture and the
politics and the economy of the country
and when you have that kind of influence
and you have no real understanding
of what the lives of most americans are
like you tend to do things
that screw over the lives of other
americans intentionally or
unintentionally
most obviously in the case of politics
and when the tea party
says we got this bunch of intellectual
elitist snobs
who think they know best how we should
live
they got a point those people do exist
and that's a kind of separation
of americans into class we've never seen
before
funny you say that they think they know
best how people should live because part
of what your argument is as i understand
it is that those people are in fact
living the sorts of lives that the lower
class should be living
are you not saying that they're staying
married they're working hard
yeah a lot of things are doing so they
do know how the other half should live
is that correct yeah but they shouldn't
be able to make laws
now by the way they are not making laws
saying people have to work and people
have to get married
they are talking about making laws about
um
how what they should eat so they aren't
as fat as they are they
they have all sorts of things with
smoking of course being the obvious
example
of going way beyond protecting people
from second-hand smoke and instead sort
of trying to enforce
that dictum about how people ought to
live their lives there are all sorts of
ways in which they are regulating
the the life out of all kinds of
occupations which prevents people from
living their lives as they see fit
um now the people at the top
are not doing a bad job of living their
own lives
what i don't want is to give them the
power to decide
how everybody else should i would like
them to say more openly
that we think that the way we're
behaving
is a good way to live say it as a
cultural statement of what's what they
consider to be right and wrong
don't use the power of the state to try
to enforce what your opinions are
i don't know how that would work i mean
uh that's why i say this i go and visit
my relatives in southwest virginia i
grew up
on a uh relatively poor on a dairy farm
and so
forth and i'm i'm regularly informed
that i got above my raisin that
i'm uh being a snob
and i'm not sure they want to hear what
i have to say about these well you know
i get this question by the way i'm not
that i i'm not
part of your i'm not a member of the if
you're ecumenical nice people
i do tell people what i think yeah but
people tell me
you know i use the phrase in the book
that that people should preach what they
practice
right and the image is that i want them
to go down to low-income communities
with bull horns you know and stand in
the corner
look go back to 1960 when there was an
extremely powerful stigma against having
a baby without a husband
incredibly powerful if you got pregnant
and you were
in most parts of american society
you went away to visit your relatives
for
for several months and the baby was put
up for adoption you know
it's an incredible statement
how did that come about i mean because
if you aren't old enough to remember
those years but i am it was not
that people preached on street corners
it was that i was raised so that i knew
that if i got my girlfriend pregnant i'd
have to marry her
and i can't even remember the specific
times my parents told me that
it was in the air and it was in the air
because it was a
cultural consensus so when i say that
a cultural consensus has enormous
effects on behavior
across the socioeconomic spectrum i am
referring to conditions which have
existed in the past
and can exist again then they will exist
when you get
conversations started that start with
thousands of conversations and
eventually go to millions of
conversations
and result in a change in the temper of
the times
what can you do to foster that you write
books
on the on the other hand that cultural
consensus also existed in a world where
it was very hard for a woman to support
her child on her own and there was no
contraception
so expectations were different so even
if you do now go back and preach
you're preaching to a completely
different world in many ways
okay now can we get back to the reason
that it's premature
to talk about solutions with policy
what do you suppose is going to happen
to policy
if once again there is a cultural
consensus
that it's terrible for kids and it's
terrible for the society
to have single births lo and behold all
sorts of policy changes
in the direction of shifting the
concrete incentives will become possible
but until that cultural shift occurs you
can't do a thing
you'll be demonizing single women if you
do well for example the republican party
right now seems to be in the process and
the elite media tend to interpret as
such of
a war on women for example for example
about rick santorum i know rick santorum
has said that contraception was a bad
idea
and he's getting crushed for it
deservedly so no he's got
i'm just making an observation of fact
that to raise that these days is not
only going to get you crushed by the
left
you are not going to have people on the
right standing up for you either
um politicians across the ideological
spectrum
are scared stiff of alienating a very
large
voter bloc namely women and more
specifically women with children and
no guy but so women without basically
think that the
deal they've got now is better than the
deal that the cultural conservatives
like you perhaps might want them to go
back to in the 1960s
well i'm saying that the issue has not
been raised in the way it needs to be
raised
that you don't do it by saying let's
have a law about contraception
you do it by talking about what happens
to children in different family
structures
you do it by talking about the objective
realities i
discussed a while ago uh and you don't
put it in terms of changing laws
you put it in terms of what's right and
wrong starting this in 1960 this is when
you were
a younger man we'll just say at that
point and
to a certain extent it could sound like
it does sound like in many cases
that you're valorizing your childhood
is there a kind of confirmation biased
by nostalgia that's going into your
analysis
well there's part of the book which says
if a time machine could appear
that could transform me back to 1960 i
would have to be dragged into a kicking
and screaming
and i described the reasons why because
life in many ways now is better than it
was then
especially for people like me and people
like you
we're doing just fine
then you can go to a hard-headed
empirical
examination of the lives of this new
lower class i'm talking about
all right if you say that satisfactions
in life
deep satisfactions in life come from one
of four
domains something i've been arguing for
years they they come from
family community vocation and faith
you don't have to tap into all four
there are happy atheists
there are happy single people but if you
don't tap into those domains
you better have a really satisfying
vocation for example or you better have
a really satisfying community life
okay what i'm describing in
the new lower class are increasing
numbers of people who aren't married
they aren't working they uh
fallen away from religion and they are
isolated
they're they're living in their
communities isolated from any
interaction with other people
those people are living lives that have
been stripped of a great deal of the
stuff
of life all right i don't consider that
argument to be nostalgic i
say that is grounded in a great deal of
our understanding
both in terms of classic aristotelian
discussions of what it means to be a
human being
and also modern empirical psychology and
sociology
i'm making the statement this is a human
tragedy
and yet i get the impression that if you
gave them the offer you could go back to
1960
they would also be like you not want to
go they go kicking and screaming yeah
yeah the reason that they aren't going
to go back to 1960
part of them are exactly the same
reasons i'm not going to okay
all right the terms of the creature
comforts and the rest of it
the other part of it is that the most
impoverished part of all is
they don't know there is anything better
out there we have kept that information
carefully to ourselves that if
people are watching take away anything i
wish they would take away this
it is non-judgmentalism run amok
to say that the person i just described
unmarried
not working no religion
no community to say well these are his
choices
and perhaps in his own way he's just as
happy as i am
that doesn't apply to you is
a form of cruelty and public policy
cannot address this
form of cruelty we have to address it
by a deep introspection into what we
most deeply believe about the sources of
satisfaction
in a human life and how do we transmit
that relive it
we live it openly and we don't make it
easy
for people to live miserable lives thank
you very much
glad you could come in and talk about it
thanks ron i enjoyed it